[Music]
imagine coming back to life after being
dead for ten hours and being 83 years
old down wait so you died a different
agent you wake up 83 no like you are 83
how in the [ __ ] did you come up with no
it was clean it was creative right cool
concept
just outside you tell me she's not that
creative I think you're pretty creative
with [ __ ] the way you've strap about
it keep her pitch mouth the way she said
it was like imagine you and your grandma
switch places after you die for it I
just saw someone that went to a tank or
10 hour coma does it that means I'm on
creative huh oh that's what you saw here
yeah I just saw a person that they went
into a 10 hour coma and then they will I
saw this like me going like this and
going oh my god I'm 83 your hands are
wrinkled your whole no but the other way
yeah the other way we got like he aged
and he woke up young jeah what's the
first thing you do you wake up you're 83
with the first Scream okay well what
have you got what do you do that right
mouth I tried I try to see like look at
what technology like because all I'm
gonna know is this cellphone but then
what if time didn't go yeah you were
just all about the hangover it's like
what hang hang what did I do my whole
life yeah the hangovers that's gonna
happen it's like 82 in the hangover Doug
13 going on 30
yeah oh I do my hey hey you know what
that's a good movie yeah 13 going on 30
right no hate for I love all the movie
references you bring up cuz they're
always like kid movies no the kid the
kid movie no I got a lot of adult
lessons from that movie okay wait we're
for you Friday Jennifer Garner is that
for your party no they're going on three
doesn't go ladies driver Jeff
Lindsay Lohan yes 32 Jennifer Garner is
don't [ __ ] your mouth what are we
talking about okay anyways this lady
died she's 83 alright
is she Wednesday afterlife for 10 hours
and she came back and I got
clarification that she was already 83
before did this turtle explained what
was in the other side she said that she
saw her dead father calling out for her
in heaven he said come on babe in life
yeah they didn't she was like I'm almost
bad bad day I believe in this respect I
believe in this [ __ ] 100% me too what
would [ __ ] old was she saying yeah but
if my dead dad was like come back I'm
like I don't want to go that way did
your dad yes please I don't know yet
yeah I'll let you know the month it's a
cliffhanger of all cliff tell you
[ __ ] in the month
wait why amman well I explained to you
on Tuesday so there's a video that comes
out yeah yeah yeah yeah I'll talk about
in that video together
that's why I added the joke okay oh no
wait why in a month
oh okay well you weren't here cuz we
were on conspiracy corner and you're not
allowed to be lot of interviews I'm not
allowed until ISIL um I'm in the middle
of doing busy things right now so I'm
used to being in limbo of not knowing
where this guy's at so I'll find out
when I get back oh it's probably best
the gate when I get back I'm trying to
be happy right now that make sense is
your dad dead or what is the funniest so
what's going on you got dad you know why
it's so funny to me is because watching
everyone's reaction yeah and then I
don't have the same relationship so
other people when they think about their
own parents that's when their that's
what the reference yes they go oh no are
you okay I'm like [ __ ] I lived most of
my life without this person but that's
why I know it's okay to clown on and
joke about 100% yeah
the way we have a relationship with
their dads except I actually am sad you
don't care yeah yeah cuz I don't know if
my dad said yeah we just hope like
that's that that's that's why it's so
funny to me like not everyone copes the
same way or has the same story or Saints
we said okay same guy the same as that
really yeah yeah okay you get me when my
parents died I will be doing so many
bits about it to the same dude that's
why your parents don't do i with someone
when you do the there's one where we did
what you were like yeah yeah my uncle
died of AIDS and I started cracking up
but what about his rated comments is
like Steve says I just wanted to thank
you for bringing that up again from for
me personally that's reminds you yeah
yeah it just reminds me of that of what
happened you know what it is it's the
absurd it's like a part of it so it's
it's not really obviously death and all
those things are pretty sad for everyone
but it's the inappropriate time of
saying it that's the comedy and I
[ __ ] hate explaining my jokes but
when people don't get it I'm like woman
from Ukraine oh oh she's so cute she's
like a typical which she looks like she
looks like that she has that [ __ ]
grimace right now she has one D'Angela
Gribble
what is he gonna do with that one tooth
she are seeing a green face just cute we
just gave me qz the two wish oh why does
she look like
but in a new door in an adorable way in
a good way
no she looks like a house to stop drop
on but in an adorable way in a beautiful
way this isn't look guys cute they're
not as fun this is during the 10 hour
with 10 hour relief that filter it's too
saturated oh it's the filter so wait so
they'd let her just chill for 10 minutes
no 10 hours oh yeah here for that one
she had a 10 hour nap no so what
happened was she was at home she felt
ill and then that's when her family
members called called paramedics over
because a relative a relative found her
without a heartbeat oh [ __ ] when they
all just assumed like okay my time has
come
and they got the paramedics also
couldn't find a heartbeat
and so the family started arranging a
priest for the funeral they started
digging her grave
and then like 10 hours later like a
family member just like checked up on
her forehead and it was warm well they
were like wait she's not dead and so
they they just said that she was in a
coma oh [ __ ] yeah but she did say that
she did go to heaven or like you know to
the afterlife cuz she talked to her dad
what are people gonna ever say I went to
hell like I'm waiting for that [ __ ]
you haven't read the book there's a book
where Dante's Inferno there's a book
where this lady had a had like she
claims she claims up there that like God
took her was it a girl I forgot now but
the point is God was a girl this
experience they said that that God took
her to hell to see like all like the
entire hell it's like yeah yeah what
it's like and then for her to write the
book mhm yeah anyway so that's this
story they finally discovered that she
was alive and so they canceled on the
plans
and but look I'm telling you guys when
they went through
weren't you seeing heaven I told you her
dad but did was her her late that
something for it for me she probably
didn't go he's probably go through the
gates yet so she had super cool her dad
was the entryway it's heaven dude
big-ass gates packed and if she wanted
to be with their dad what her dad she
said that once she regained
consciousness that she saw people all
around her wearing white so she thought
they were angels but they were doctors
or they could be the KKK yeah oh the
cake cake I could have been the cake
cake cake what in Ukraine what if her
homegirl brought her back she was on her
way to heaven in [ __ ] stupid ass [ __ ]
touched her forehead and then with oh
she teleported her nose man for real
like be like I'm trying to picture being
this lady in her situation since 83
she's already so old like she saw her
dad she's probably happy yeah like hell
yeah take me to heaven yeah but then she
wakes up she's like yeah I'm still here
yeah she looks already happy it are just
like heaven better if she likes here
better yeah true story not a bit
oh wait she did say that God had mercy
on her and then like brought her back to
life why would that be mercy if that
feels better
Tory not a bit true story not a bit my
grandpa when he was dying horribly died
in horrible horrible agony liver failure
and stage liver failure drinking too
much throughout his entire life
he when he was near death's door he woke
up and he told everyone he was like hey
I just like I just met this beautiful
woman named Frieda and that's my grandma
my grandma's name and he's like and it's
just before that he's like he's like I
am going to marry this woman so he was
like and your grandma had passed before
no my grandma is alive but wherever he
like wherever he was dreaming about he
was like a younger man and like he was
and he was seeing he's like bests her
seeing his favorite what were he wanted
his life to go as a young man and I just
yeah I believe that [ __ ] bro cuz it went
the other way
well no it's good it's all it's actually
really beautiful because he was like an
80 year old man when he died so it's
like oh
you have to have that life with Freda
like it happened like you like the
notebook yeah my grandma had a divorce
with ha
because he was an alcoholic that Gamble
waived the family fortune but she
doesn't have any memory of that and I
thought that was sweet
Oh cuz I would visit her at the hall and
then she's all like you should meet my
husband he's coming home soon and I'm
all like little do you know you [ __ ]
forgetful [ __ ] he's dead no but I was
feeling that and I was just like that's
a good funny grandma I should have
[ __ ] with her a little bit more
because I knew that there wouldn't be
any consequence yo check this out I had
a homegirl right we're all in Vegas
drunk on New Year's and then um she was
dating my boy at the time or they're so
together but anyways so he was drunk too
and she he was trying to carry her back
to the hotel because they were both like
super drunk he [ __ ] dropped her on
her head they took her to the hospital
Hospital declared her dead yes they were
like she's dead but they brought her
back to life the doctor goes she did
like she's dead and but they brought her
back to life and then the next day she
[ __ ] had a bandage on her head and we
were like clubbing again she was just
like he doesn't hurt I guess not
ah give me that Cooke the group split up
so we didn't hear about the Scylla the
next day they're like bro they said she
was dead and they brought her back Wow
now she's at the Tropicana shots all
night near-death experiences you
actually don't die and then you came
back I guess because you were in debt I
mean I can't call it came back cuz if
they call it a death experience than
like you know you're dead they should
make it sound like something else is
near partially doesn't like ya cuz it
sounds like you didn't even die look I'm
sure there's a scientific term but
they're also pourin yeah
[Music]
[Music]